ich stehe zusammen mit vitali klitschko
dem bürgermeister von kiew in schweren
stunden vitali es gibt eine offensive
weiterhin auf die stadt die ja die stadt
einkesseln will wie ist die aktuelle
militärische lage
kann ist hauptstadt ist das viel vom
russischen die wohlen stadt kommen und
baby stadt zu besetzen
ich möchte meine gedanken an auch einige
soldaten weil es die richtige helden
seit zwölf tagen schon verteidigen
unsere hauptstadt und
russen wollen an kesseln die stadt
gvb brechen der alle pläne das ist so
unsere soldaten brille übrigen alle
lernen und dass wir uns beteiligen
unserer stadt das ist eine richtige
schlacht wo es schon seit wochen im buch
the storm ardian grad das ist eine
nebenstelle dass es etliche städte vor
hauptstadt das ist ungefähr von
her2 und 15 kilometer vom zentrum
könnten die soldaten die russischen
soldaten hier seien niemals niemals die
kommen niemals wasser des stadtstaates
nicht nur gebäude statt dass es die
leute wäre weil liebten die letten die
stadt und ich möchte eine sache um so
eine riesige party israel ist noch nie
gelesen bin durch eine mich treffen
verschiedene leute auf der straße alle
hassen russische aggression alle alle
wollen und jede hat eine riesige will
und wunsch unserer stadt verteidigt und
sind zum beispiel das ist eine
verteidigungsposition
wo man kann
freiwillig kommen freiwillige
verteidigung dass es seine waffe
gekommen die schlangen dass es leute
stehen stundenlang war von zu bekommen
dass es verschiedene eine
gründliche berufe zum beispiel habe ich
ärzten getroffen die musiker sogar
theater
karski theaterschauspieler
klerikern normale zivilisten sich gegen
eine russische armee jetzt unterstützt
wird von tschetschenischen kämpfern die
hoch ausgebildet ist die technisches
gerät deswegen dass wegen nicht nur für
alle gedanken wer unterstützung einer
als unterstützung ohne unsere ohne
unsere freunde unterstützer und beliebt
seit langer zeit nicht mehr gegen russ
charme und deswegen wir brauchen eine
moderne war verteidigungswaffen die
graphen kann ich habe schon zigmal
gesagt wir sind eine hand eine afrika
genau noch was kann deutschland tun wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine helme
schusswesten wir brauchen eine richtige
wahl für moderne waffen weil er wir
kämpfen nicht durch einen messestand
deutschland wie gehen wir nicht uns
verteidigen nicht nur reiner wir
verteidigen die ganze werden
wir verteidigen die prinzipen was gibt
europäische union die haben genug wasser
wir haben genug lebensmittel auf dem
gedanken eine
unterstützung für
jugendhilfe was bekommen wir auch aus
deutschland wir haben circa zwei wochen
die unsere ware zwei wochen die großer
teil von bevölkerung
anwohner von käfig schon nie da ist viel
prozent sind noch in der stadt von den
sieg haben wir haben wir haben gezielt
normalerweise vor dem krieg
gezahlt von
anwohner war 3 und 5 millionen 3 5
millionen auch heute weniger als zwei
millionen das bedeutet fast die hälfte
schon zwei millionen ist ja noch ne ist
da schon noch eine riesige zahl an
zivilisten dennoch sieht man in den
straßen kaum mehr menschen weil sie sich
alle versteckten in den häusern in den
keller ich biete hier der ohne ohne
grund niemals auf der straße zu gehen
dass es weil dort das risiko gleiches
außenministerin annalena baerbock zu
gast war bild live was ist die nachricht
der appell des bürgermeisters von kiew
an die deutsche außenminister
die durchaus der minister möchte ich
noch einmal bedanken für unterstützung
und wir brauchen wir brauchen
unterstützung von deutschland wir
brauchen waffen unterstützung weil wir
bekämpfen nicht nur frieden in unserem
land bekämpfen den frieden in ganz
europa auch in deutschland sie müssen
das begreifen und du noch einmal schnell
keine im wirtschaftliche beziehung mit
russland wie hier der euro was bekommt
russland investieren nicht in seiner
wirtschaftlichen nicht in sein vor den
visieren in army und danach gekommen sie
solche bilder wie aus hochreiner
deswegen
keine geschäftliche beziehung weil putin
hat eine idee
russisch zu retournieren wieder
aufzubauen ich möchte ein fragen
ehemalige erde der anwohner wollen sie
zurück zum der
menschenrechte freiheit spielt keine
rolle für sie dann kenntnisse weiter
russland unterstützen und habe ich schon
gesagt er wisse nicht wurde endet die
verrückte idee
sowjetische imperium aufzubauen
ich habe schon viel gesprochen und der
grenze von porz ich schließe nicht aus
dass es jemals der auch in pläne von
wladimir putin